this is a segment we call third and
short but i kept the last segment a
little tighter because i liked our
questions better in third and short so
this week it is third and long here we
go question number one who is coach of
the year rod through four weeks coach of
the year i love the question we begin
with where are you leaning i got to go
with i got to go out to arizona i mean
i'm going out with my former teammate
cliff kingsbury i mean at the job that
he's done with kyler murray in
particular i mean from a leadership
standpoint and to what he's doing on the
field is absolutely tremendous you tell
me somebody more deserving than than
cliff kingsbury
i may go and i have a few names that are
on my chart here i think i'd have to go
coach staley though with the chargers
because coming into this year is herbert
going to be able to stay where he was is
the defense going to be able to go over
the top you know just become an elite
defense check check maybe both of them
are better than i thought they would be
so the chargers right now in my head are
a definite team a definite team that
could be playing a home super bowl so
it's hard for me to not go a team that
for so long has been really not even a
playoff you know really maybe not even
make the playoffs let alone make a deep
playoff run and right now they feel like
a team that definitely could so i'm
going coach staley
hey brother let me tell you and that was
my second choice i think he's done a
wonderful job just the confidence that
he's built on a defensive side of the
ball but also just think about the
charges the last 10 or 12 years that
we've been covering them they've always
had talent but it's always been a team
whether it's special teams issues
whether it was discipline penalties
they've always lost close games and now
you see brandon staley have these guys
believing and being able to finish games
so
you can't go wrong with either one of
these guys i think both of them are
doing a tremendous job
i'm right there with you you cannot go
wrong with either one and you you gave
me both of them so we were both leaning
the exact same way here is a few other
names i want to work into this
conversation though think about somebody
who was on the chopping block who was if
things didn't go well this year he was
going to get fired and now he's gone the
complete opposite direction to start the
season zach taylor in cincinnati i am
very impressed with what he's doing and
i think what the genius of what he's
doing more than anything else
and he did it in the draft and now he's
doing it on the field is letting this be
joe burrows team just letting it be his
it's like something that green bay never
did with aaron rodgers it's something
that i think the bucks are doing a
masterful job of with tom brady if you
go out there maybe the rams and stafford
the way that they trust him they are
just putting complete and utter belief
into joe burrow in joe burrow's mind and
who joe burrow is as a leader and it's
because he's the perfect guy to bet on
and i from what i heard of that that
final fourth quarter against
jacksonville burroughs said put me in
empty and i'm gonna pick this team apart
guess what he did coach taylor put him
in empty and guess what burrow did he
picked him completely apart so i got to
give love to zach taylor three-in-one
tied for first place in the afc north i
think it's been incredible what he's
doing in cincinnati
amen brother and he's in a when he has
confidence in the quarterback and he
allows a young guy with such freedom
then everybody else is pumped up like
man if coach believes in him like that
we believe in him so these guys are
playing on a different level joe mixon
behind that offensive line i see guys
roughing people pushing and standing up
that's what you want and and i just i've
been really impressed with their
toughness that that they're displaying
i got two others i'm gonna float out
there that i think need love maybe you
pick who you think needs more love
between them sean mcdermott with buffalo
watching buffalo play they were tough in
the red zone but man i just i think
about this team with josh allen playing
quarterback and how much better he's
gotten this defensive front getting a
whole bunch of pressure great safety
play back there good linebacker in
edmonds he had a pick this week and if
you take away some of the struggles they
had in the red area i just thought they
look so good man i'm thinking about the
play where josh allen broke out i think
it was the very first play of the second
quarter he broke out and he broke this
defensive lineman's tackle and he's
running to the right and diggs is 40
yards down the field he's on the run and
he just put a laser beam on the sideline
diggs almost couldn't believe it hit him
in the hands and he's just one guy that
i don't think defensive lineman want to
go up against because he can beat you
with power he can beat you with speed
they lose to the steelers and they've
been great ever since then as they head
into kansas city on sunday night so sean
mcdermott and mike mccarthy with the
cowboys would be my next three and four
if you will they're at the top of the
league right now with the coaching jobs
they're doing yeah i i agree yeah i'm
sorry i agree with you you i mean guys
are just they're winning their teams
believe in them they're playing
extremely hard no doubt i agree with you
on those guys
beautiful we gave a lot of love right
there cool let's get to the best rookie
quarterback
so we're through week four right so this
this fourth week and maybe if you want
to even go the whole season who has been
the most impressive rookie quarterback
to you
it has to be mac jones and i think
that's an easy one because he's
replacing the goat anytime you can
replace you're replacing the goat and
people aren't clamoring for tom brady
they're actually content with who you
are and you proved on sunday what type
of quarterback that you can be a guy
that had i don't know how many
completions did he have nine or ten or
something like that in a row just a
whole bunch of completions he's poised
he's under control he's disciplined and
he loves football and
that's all you can ask for a young guy
that wants it josh mcdaniels excited i
know i'm excited
yeah i think we saw mac jones would be
my number one we saw a better version of
justin fields after fields basically
negative one yards of net offense a week
ago and you're going his confidence is
going to be destroyed for him to come
back look a lot better trevor lawrence
played in my opinion his best game of
the year
thursday against cincinnati that
probably boils
so much frustration as well into urban
meyer when he probably felt like that
was finally the game and it takes time
like september football with a rookie
quarterback and a rookie head coach in
the nfl it's gonna take time and i
thought it was the first moment where we
saw it look like an urban buyer offense
and we saw it look like trevor lawrence
and he was even a little cocky like i
remember that touchdown run he's like
looking up and talking trash to the
bangles in the stands he's gonna have to
have an edge man he's gonna have to play
quarterback with an edge in jacksonville
he's gonna have to take this team to
another level because it's hard to go
win games as a jaguars you're not going
to have good wide receivers and you're
not going to have an unbelievable
defense you're going to have to wear
that on your shoulders and i thought for
the first time in the first half of that
game we saw trevor lawrence look his
best in the nfl so i got to show some
love to lawrence as well
and i'm not showing any love to his head
coach because his head coach has to be a
lot more responsible and make sure that
he's on that plane talking to his young
rookie quarterback talking to his team
and letting them know that hey guys even
though we've gone through some adversity
i am here with you now maybe he could
have been excused if he had to go to a
funeral or something like that but to go
check on your restaurant a bar come on
man you got handlers you got people that
can do that type of stuff for you the
most important thing for you to do as
the head coach is to be with your team
so
we'll see what happens but i'm telling
you those guys lost a lot of respect for
urban meyer in that locker room
if you were a leader inside the
jacksonville locker room if you were a
leader star safety on that team a leader
of the defense what kind of
conversations would you have with
teammates and with urban directly
well if i were on that team more than
likely i probably and i'm not saying
this from a cocky standpoint i've
probably been one of the captains or
leaders on that team so i would have had
a conversation with some of the other
captains or veterans of that team and we
would have took our concerns to the head
coach and if we weren't satisfied with
what the coach was saying then if if i
knew we had to go one step higher then
we have to go to ownership but coach
would definitely have to explain instead
of just saying i'm sorry you know and
everybody makes mistakes but at the same
time
you're urban meyer you've been in this
game a long time you've won national
championships you've done a lot of great
things in college football and you
should know the difference between right
and wrong and that was definitely the
wrong thing to do
yeah my mind's just exploding on the
fact that he thought he could get away
with it that's the one thing that i just
i can't there's cameras everywhere with
everything on film
everything
is on film everything
everything is on film so for him like
even rodney's umbrella is on film so for
him to feel like he's going to get away
with something like this it's insane to
me and i think about he was probably was
drinking his sorrows away i mean that's
probably what it was i mean he goes up
there i mean if you look at some of the
pictures of video as a drink his eyes
kind of look all like i think he was in
a bad frame of mind but it is no excuse
when you are a 50 something maybe even
60 something year old man to go act like
that let's get to your third one get
back to some of these positives you
wanted to give a little props to the big
men so one offensive lineman or one
defensive lineman that caught your eye
who would that be this week
jason kelsey has been one of my favorite
players i've watched him i love his
ability to to pull he's always hustling
this is a guy that just plays he's a
veteran player but he plays with so much
enthusiasm he plays so tough and he was
the only starting offensive lineman on
the field with philly and you just watch
this guy hustling and he just crushes
the cornerback this is a center that's
been in the league a long time and just
it's incredible the hustle that he had
down the field he's down the field look
at him right at the 10 yard line he just
knocks the corner out
they don't even score a touchdown on
that particular play but at the same
time man what a just a great hustle play
by him props to jason kelsey still
getting it done even though they drafted
landon dickerson to replace him
that's a great one that's a great one
right there i'm thinking about the
packers offensive line because we
mentioned earlier all those huge holes
that they were creating and it was it
was you know seven eight nine yards down
the field before aaron jones or aj
dillon was getting touched and the
creative ways that they use dylan in the
passing game is awesome too
but i think about david bakhtiari coming
back i mean the fact that he is still
out when he finally works his way back
to healthy with this offensive line and
they continue to hit in the draft i mean
this front office while they've had some
issues with rogers josh myers out of
ohio state that's another big stud that
they have hit playing center looking
really good newman another one so they
are they are building this offensive
line right if bacori comes back
green bay i know we hit on jair
alexander and his injury now with the
shoulder and that's a big one but if
they can get this offensive line right
man that's going to be something right
there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports